feel good hello and welcome
to the feels good podcast i'm
amanda cerny and i have jacqueline
fernandez and we also
have a very special guest with us today
and instead of our feel good stories we
have
amazing feels good guests with us and
jacqueline
i'll let you do the intro woohoo okay i
am so
super excited to introduce our first
celebrity guest on our show
you are our first guest
so this is really exciting it's an
exciting time as well we are celebrating
the bali
uh so it's a super special time for us
and seth
needs no introduction he is a
national award winner one of our most
loved celebrity
one of our most loved stars actors
producers
um he is you're you're a padma shri
winner yes uh he comes from this
really beautiful family of royalty he's
a
toady yeah okay
i'm just like i have to make sure
everything is right yeah
you're looking at him for approval
you're like yes wait i'm super
okay the thing is about seth i have to
tell you before i came into
before i came to india before i came to
bollywood my favorite actor from india
was seth no i swear i swear to god like
there was
i would like see your films okay he has
some of the most iconic films the most
iconic characters
um and for me like seth is like this
like especially when i came as well i
couldn't believe i had this opportunity
to work with you and now it's our second
film together as well
um such a super cool guy apart from
being this brilliant actor
uh he's just like super suave like to me
he's like the super suave super chic
really intelligent reads a lot of books
not like my fake reading
uh which we discussed the other day i
fake read a lot
oh fake readings when you have a book
and then like you get through like three
pages and then you get to turn the print
and then you put it away and you come
back to it after four months and then
you post about it
and you're like just read this book and
then like you feel
so like i mean divine when you've read
like those five pages and then
better than no pages yeah exactly i have
loads of books and a lot of them i've
gone through but like a lot of them are
just like half
written and or half read that's exactly
the same as me yeah a lot of them are
not supposed to read everything
really i thought when you you pick up a
book you're supposed to
well i mean you know i've failed often
and sometimes you get through it
well yeah and then you keep it i mean i
i kind of
have books that i think would be really
interesting to read um and i haven't
read them all but i plan to
well you know it's kind of like my plan
is like sometimes we don't always make
it true
yeah we don't always make it through a
film right so it's like sometimes you
just don't maybe you don't really enjoy
the book that you're reading and you're
like
i heard a really nice spanish writer say
something amazing about books where
um he used to travel a lot as a kid
because his father was a diplomat
and he used to start feeling a little
insecure going to um
various places that he can recognize but
he took his books with him and he took
about five or six
classics or whatever he liked because he
knew that on such and such page
this would happen wow and that gave him
a sense of security and a sense of
you know uh wherever he is in the world
he'd take him to a new hotel or a new
house
he knows i'm paying 865 you know
this is what's going to happen with don
quixote or with pinocchio
he enjoyed that security wow
comforting comforting it is and there's
a beautiful book place so we are
shooting for a film right now in terms
of
and there is i don't know if you saw it
on the way here there's this quaint
little bookstore
no i didn't oh i like the town it's
amazing i want to go for a walk amanda
you're invited
to adding it to the list
the places i'm going with jacqueline
yeah we've already had like some
stepping stones to visit
this this should be one of them for sure
yeah is so
special and like so yeah on the way here
in the market i saw this really quaint
bookstore and all i could think about
was like oh my god seth is gonna
love what books do you carry with you on
this trip i've carried a couple of
ghost story books the oxford book of
ghost stories the best collection of
ghost stories ever
it starts in you know one of the early
ghost stories is written in about
1600 and something um and it goes on for
about now so
the editor has collected how the ghost
story has changed and evolved over
the years and it's to do with technology
i think when people started inventing
the radio and you could hear voices um
from far away then people started
thinking maybe you can hear voices from
other
dimensions or things like that so um
it's fascinating
so ghost story books a couple of those
and um there's one by
a a kind of a psychiatrist called m
scott tech called further down the road
less traveled which
i think helps people i shouldn't laugh
it's but it's nice it's nice to get some
yeah paterno
it's really funny that you are reading
about ghost
stories yeah because we are actually
making
a couple of books oh you are it is you
guess what guess who he's reading ivana
yeah
so she's also trained under her
fantastic
really nice book to read yeah and uh
what else i think oh yeah i've got the
de cameron
which is bokaccio's old book it's like
chaucer's precursor to
the contributors written during a
pandemic as well actually
pandemic and uh
what else and and john dryden's
translation of the init
which is the story of aeneas and troy
you know escaping from
the burning of troy and setting up the
roman empire in
well i find that so interesting though i
just don't know where you're getting the
time to read all these books
i'm not all the time i'm feeling so bad
right now because i'm like yeah i'm
mindless uh the thing is i know exactly
where they are
and i know that these are the books that
are in my room and if i
find myself literally bored or lost i
can entertain myself in various ways
yeah actually i think that's the best
thing about books like i always care
like i said like i
am a fake reader so i always make sure i
carry a bunch of books with me like
right now i have a book called
it's such a great book but i'm still
halfway through it's called a female
brain
okay nice but it is so interesting
because it talks about like i keep you
know ranting on about this how like
we're all about evolution and we're all
about reproduction and we're all about
like
survival like even so yeah i feel like
our emotions as well are all just like
manipulated because it's all about us
just surviving and reproducing
and so anyways though the female brain
goes into like so many so many reasons
like women do the things that they do
and how we're structured how we're made
and how we're performed
no just like yeah to reproduce um how
our moods happen
how we grow up when we're kids what
happened to us when you know so it's
like
just our formation how we're so how we
are actually so different from men
um yeah and just like so it's a super
interesting book i can't wait to get to
the end i don't know how long it's gonna
take
a lot of men online um
about buddhism and uh psychology
which it was something similar to what
you're saying about um saying how we're
conditioned a certain way
from the beginning of kind of time and
you know
evolution i mean the idea is to kind of
fight against our natural instincts um
you know which are basically to
reproduce
but that's not socially acceptable all
the time
which gets us in lots of problems but
that's what it is it's the most
natural thing like you know so
yeah we had a bit of a chat this morning
about that amanda came up with a fun
fact
the best time well yeah the best time to
reproduce
is it's after a workout it's in the
morning what after a workout
i thought morning time too i was like oh
for sure it's the morning you know
jump start the day and then after after
a workout
when you're home after workout when
you're pumped up and the blood is
flowing
oh nice yeah it was a really great
discussion point we had
we had a lot of fun so
amanda we are having diwali yeah and
happy
diwali to the both of you guys to
everyone
yeah i know it's like i'm like
celebrating on my own
over here in uh in la but i'm sure a
bunch of other people are celebrating
too
um well i know for well for those of you
who don't know diwali is a five-day
hindu celebration known as the festival
of lights it celebrates the victory
of good over evil light over darkness
and
i love that so much and knowledge over
ignorance which preach is very important
and is celebrated by
billions of hindus six and jane's
across the world so so awesome
yeah seth's family is actually flying in
they're going to be here like in a few
hours
yes they're floating they're driving up
now oh they're driving up now
oh my gosh like his son is so super cute
i can't wait to see him oh my gosh
he is so hilarious he's like four years
old and he's just
like the cutest cutest thing seth what
is like the one thing you've learned
from tamora
like what is like something i think you
know he's incredibly kind
and he's much kinder than um sometimes
like i
i mean i try and be kind but he's more
patient
and kinder than i am um he's very
i mean he's just very warm to all the
people who work with us
um and everyone we meet in our lives
he's constantly watching and
and he's learned by example if i say
something
even is slightly off tone he says you
know
abba you can be nicer than that so wow
yeah so he's quite
he's a bit of a you know um parent to me
in that sense where
we both correct each other if we step
out of line which i think
i love yeah oh that's great though i
think there is so much to learn from
kids
yeah and you have another one on the way
yes
[Laughter]
can you can you break down your whole
your family
for everybody listening that doesn't
know just like it's so interesting
like how everybody's in entertainment
and it's just like you
you're my mother my mother is an actor
and
uh my so my mother's family is from the
tagore family
and my great-grand uncle was robin
not to go who was a you know nobel
laureate and he won a nobel prize and
i think he in and he was knighted by the
british as well but he gave both those
things back
um after atrocities committed by
um the colonial british ruling india
who were you know shooting people and
things like this so he said he kind of
returned the knighthood
so so a lot of them were artists um
you know the tagos like great painters
and poets
and things like this so my mother's from
that kind of thing she's been doing
films since she was 16.
um she worked with sachitith ray a lot
um who's a very famous indian director
and so he worked with him when she was
16 and did about four or five movies i
think
she was his muse in in many ways he kind
of thought of her as the
ultimate female representation of his
art
so there was that and um then my sisters
in in kind of movies
and you know my wife um
and um my ex-wife as well
um so all of us like everyone my
daughter
yeah and and you know my son eldest son
wants to be an actor
and i think then we will be an actor for
sure he's
entertaining us already yeah we know
from now already
and he's kind of super talented he's
just all into movies
i think he's a wonderful profession you
know so that means you knew you wanted
to be an actor
no i was a big mess i do but also my
father was a he's from a completely
different
um field yeah different feel and a
different upbringing like like
um jacqueline said that i mean there
used to be
sort of ruling princes and had a whole
different set of
ideas and uh acting on front of a camera
wasn't necessarily
something that came very naturally to
that kind of thing yeah um so
there was there were some pulls in
different directions and i didn't know
where i wanted to go what i was capable
of
and i was sent to a very academic school
in my father's footsteps and
that didn't go prec nicely as planned i
think the idea was to become lawyer or
doctor or something
and our generation in delhi growing up
in the 80s
um work i think we're the first people
in india really to say okay we don't
want to become
doctors or lawyers or kind of engineers
or these safe jobs that you're trying to
give us
um and we'd rather be some kind of
artist a lot of dress designers like
you know rohit baal and all these guys
we used to party together when we were
17 18 and
they were already starting to do these
amazing things um so it was never going
to be something regular
but it was a bit it was a bit worrying
for my parents when i was 18 19 because
i knew it wasn't going to be a 9-5 job
and when films came along that sounded
like really exciting thing but it's
something i was
kind of kept away from growing up it
wasn't did you watch like all your mom's
forms
no no and i watched one and then she was
wearing the same outfit
that she wore at home because i think it
was a low budget film and she'd worn her
own clothes wow
to kind of help them out and then she
was crying a lot because the films were
very melodramatic
um and you are much like italian movies
you're either playing you know
i mean i think she was playing
some kind of a sex worker
who was had been abused and lost her
face it was traumatizing
it was called mossam and she was smoking
and she was drinking and losing her mind
and crying
how old were you i was very young i was
um you know
my i was about six or seven and anyway i
started crying
and then i didn't watch hindi films
because i thought the two melodramatic
two yeah emotionally sort of training
yeah
all melodramatic and really long really
long they used to be really long you
could hear them through the house you
know
usually this mother crying yeah and the
background music playing
i remember this like growing up in
bahrain um so like every because there
was no cable there was just like the
local
television so you just watched whatever
they
you know they gave in india so there was
doordarshan there was only
two movies there's a movie on saturday
that was it yes so we only had we had
hindi films
every wednesday night they used to play
but i remember
the slot was from 9 00 p.m to 12 p.m and
they filled up the whole
like it was like they were really really
long it's like gone with the wind
the ten commandments type of like like
the length was really really long
now of course with like downstairs
life's changed i mean
i think the idea is still i it's
interesting how things tie up together i
think in india
sometimes unless you're here it's
difficult to go out
i mean you don't really care of a family
taking their kids out and feeding the
ducks or kind of going for a walk
so going to the movies is really kind of
the only family outing
so yeah sometimes there used to be a bit
longer there was no
kind of rock and roll industry or music
industry
um so a few years ago you'd
get everything from the movie whether it
was music whether it was your rock star
whether it was your poet
so all those different um types of art
um which you can actually find in
different places normally
were found in one movie so it's probably
stretched a bit long as well
have to get a full day out of it
absolutely yeah that's true a whole
outing
yeah but so there's oh sorry let me go
ahead man
oh no it's fine um i mean that's
that's so interesting that it's kind of
something that you
fell into and you decided on your own
like there was no really
obviously you're surrounded by actors
super talented actors your whole family
but
and then you deciding okay well or your
mother at least and then you deciding
at what point were you like okay this is
the route i'm gonna take this is what
i'm going to do and
did you have kind of a leg up um after
somebody's put some money on you for
whatever reason i mean a producer
generally will think
if he can possibly sell an idea and if
it helps him you try and sell it
but nobody's gonna put you know good
money after bad
i mean if something goes wrong yeah um
yeah
you know you lose and then nobody's
gonna i mean a brother won't support a
brother beyond the point you know so
i i've started saying you know blood is
thicker than water but
film is thicker than blood you know
you you lose your family over that's a
t-shirt option so like we keep
we keep looking pretty good yeah i'm
writing writing it down
i like that one that one's like edgy
yeah that one's good
we needed that but
you're not on social media right like
know i haven't seen i was like all right
let me check out all of his socials and
stuff and i'm like he's
he's off the grid where is he there's
articles for days about you
i mean i i anticipated old fashioned in
the sense that i like doing press the
way we're doing it now
um when you talk to someone and i mean
it's fine i would do it but i just think
it would distract me from
i went for a nice walk today and i was
looking at this church
at the bottom of this hill and it's
beautiful and i thought i tried to take
a picture of it
and i i started photographing it but i
stopped enjoying the church
so i thought i can't do both you know um
it's better for me to experience things
and just
talk to people and do the you know just
live the life i'm living in in the way i
am
but i think it's great that other people
do it because i like to look at what
other people are up to
and i like to look at the world through
their eyes
and it's really nice there's no
judgement i mean it's unfortunate that
we can't be just original in our
thoughts sometimes
you're always made to feel that if
you're not doing is either something
wrong with you or something wrong with
the person who is doing it
there's nothing like that it's just you
know it's just it's almost kind of
envious right now
like because like social media when it
started
for for me it was i think this was six
years ago maybe i got onto
instagram and it was just this really
really fun
thing this fun platform to upload your
pictures
and an aesthetic it was like for
photographers actually i was like oh my
god like
i want to be this you know like
everything just like it was a very cool
thing to do
that's so that's so true i totally
forgot that
it didn't help the video right away yeah
don't have any of that it was just
beautiful aesthetic pictures and i
remember like
putting up sunsets putting up like you
know chai and afternoon chai
and then it just it just you know became
it grew into something
that almost became you know beyond our
control a lot of people's control
um i mean it has a really ugly side to
it as well
people keep bringing up my wife and
saying can you post this and can you do
that and i think that's good
inclusive no and they must be asking you
you have so many it's so funny
to two years or three years into social
media because it became this huge
phenomena so like then i exactly i
started feeling the intrusion i started
feeling people
like hanging on you know or people just
wanting that one post or people just
wanting that one picture on your
platform
and then everything just became kind of
like disillusioned and like
fake and inauthentic and and i i was
getting like
pretty like stressed by it and now i i
think i've found my balance where i know
like yeah my phone's quite instagram i
mean instagram worthy
i love taking pictures oh i know i'll
think you should make a book
maybe i don't know there you go put it
up one day
yeah the coffee table you're doing your
book but someone asked me to do a book
and i'm kind of i might chicken out
because i was just thinking
because it's too much work to do it
properly and then you have to be very
honest as well which
probably will disturb quite a few people
but don't think
that that's what we need right now yeah
but no i don't know i
honestly don't know if i am prepared to
put myself through
the hundred percent abuse that's gonna
come my way i don't think i'm
i'm really sorry to say it i'm gonna say
it i don't think the general audience
and not the general but there's just too
much there will be a section of audience
that's so negative in india yeah
that i don't want to share my life and
talk about things um
because actually i haven't even told the
publishers that i'm thinking i'm not
doing it
we started doing
when i was walking today part of the
book should describe what i was feeling
and thinking
looking at these trees and thinking how
lucky we are to be shooting in himachal
and
you know all this and it's not really
because so why isn't it because so
basically me and amanda started this
podcast because
during quarantine we realized how
negative
the world had become and obviously there
was it was this really crazy situation
people were losing jobs there was
just you know people's frustrated yeah
stressed
a lot of that stuff so we decided to
make this podcast called the feels good
podcast we're like we will only discuss
really positive things and like so we
pick up like positive news from around
the world like random stuff
we pick up like really weird fun facts
so that's cool because and
and your your media is really negative
oh my god i like it
i mean you you turn on this is one of
the positives yeah but again my
i'm sorry to bring in the negative but
don't bring
let me rephrase this i'm saying uh yes i
think i'll have to work hard to find the
right balance between you know artistic
description
inner kind of dialogue about what one
feels and to read to kind of decide how
personal you want to get
yeah that's the thing and i think it
could be a really good platform to kind
of
you know share some experiences so many
people as well that actually want to
just like read your thoughts and and
learn a little bit from you and about
you
and it's just like your memoirs and i
think it's just it's just
you know certain things are just lost if
you don't
write them down absolutely and you have
kids as well so they can always like
i mean it's something they can if i have
a friend actually it's a good idea i
have a friend of mine who said
yes i've been busy writing my memoirs my
kids come in and say what are you doing
and he says no no listen you'll thank me
one day
but he hasn't spent any time with them
this is for you this is the key to your
future
that's his social media
it's quite easy to kind of delete
yourself his memoirs is his
social media his version he's like
his notepad i'm excited for that i'm
going to try and do it i'm going to try
and do it properly and just
yeah and in a different way but i think
it's going to it can't be done easily i
mean they had an idea where i just kind
of narrate it to
a writer and then we run through various
topics
but i think it it requires some effort
sitting down and thinking and writing
and coming from the heart
you can't just be an intelligence yes
you gotta be raw maybe it's your life
through your pictures
it could be you know my wife made a
really moving film
for me uh cut to some of our you know
favorite
songs so she had like what things i
missed the most by steely dan
and she cut um 50 years of my life
in pictures starting off with me like in
my father's
arms wow and that's a lot of work
yeah i mean still
exist i think she hired an agency to
help but she kept from the pictures and
directed the whole thing which was
also that's a huge effort as well
it was so moving i was like very close
to tears if i if i wasn't
sociopathically unempathetic
how do you get yourself to cry in your
films
will you know stick something in my eye
and sort of think about
losing something well you know
i i can fake it a bit but it's not my it
doesn't come to me
easily as it comes to some people okay
it's difficult i made these blocks
so i find it difficult to get around i
can laugh quite easily
i think it's the damage of boarding
school oh yeah
like just like kind of like well it kind
of toughens you up but it also
i don't know if toughen up means block
emotionally
i think it could knock that as well
that's what's happening in boarding
schools are you guys like afraid to cry
no no um actually we went to a very
liberal boarding school as far as
english boarding schools go
because you know 20 years before that
there was caning and
a system called fagging which might not
happen
and all the junior boys come running and
the last guy to arrive gets the dirty
job and he has to
go and clean my shoes and make sure
they're shiny why was it called baggage
yeah what was the name that was mean
yeah
yeah it's crazy are your kids being
homeschooled
just being different things that's true
you should make a list of those
but that's in your book things i've
observed
there's many different names
have you have you created i mean you're
producing which is
amazing like when did you start getting
into producing
alongside you know when i joined the
movies there was
a system in place where the big powerful
filmmakers would be making these movies
and and you probably wouldn't get paid
much to be doing their movies because it
was an honor and a privilege because
these
movies are going to be really well made
and they'll probably do well and then
you make your money elsewhere
that was the idea um but when actually
kishore lula of
eros uh entertainment came to town he
was a big
he had big ideas and what he did was he
kind of gave
some of us who were doing all right
movies and some who were doing obviously
very well
i was doing all right and he said why
don't you make your own movie and i'll
give you the money let's cut out the
middleman
um i'll distribute it you should put it
together
wow and think like you know shahrukh is
thinking for example
so he gave us lots of money and we
started doing it ourselves so we formed
a company
financed by somebody else um
which is great but it's not as gutsy
as really putting your own money in
because then you really
then you really own the show but you
know i find that so difficult for an
actor like
when you are acting in a film that
you're also financing putting your money
in
like i feel it would like you know like
we go into stores right now we're
just going there we act we do this we do
a couple but like when you know like
wait a minute the money is going here
this is
i don't know if like that would
compromise it would come from
it's not easy because you know an actor
is used to certain kind of uh
perks and a certain way of working and
there's demands on you but there's also
you know you can relax so you're used to
living a certain way if you're were
producer and you'd be getting calls
saying you know why is my
bedroom not cold or warm or whatever
exactly and that you know you haven't
signed on for you
like sorry reading my scripts how to
learn my lines
the magic of a movie is when everyone
comes together and does their [ __ ] yeah
i agree you know the actor
does his bit and the producer does his
bit and they're all different
very different parts to this whole i
know the directed tools and all that you
know
i think production is super difficult
it's an art and it's a
very creative field and it's not
necessarily just money you know
yeah but it is a business it is business
yeah
yeah it's just like third lines but it's
fun it's very
device to really i would love the idea
of having a small production to come up
with an idea and say okay this should be
a movie
and someone says no that's not a movie
that's actually a short story
but that's a book it's not a film or
it's a short film it's a web show
no this is a mainstream commercial movie
that should be 3d
that's the producer's kind of art if you
can make that call how much money to put
on this story
you know which is basically i'm not sure
i never looked at it that way actually
that is like a major call to take
right and who to take and how to make it
and how much to make it in
i said no that's too much for like but
you know or you say no
take them let's go to himachal and shoot
it and spend it but police is the film
that we're shooting for right now
it's a horror comedy and it's coming out
next year i can't wait
i can't wait to see it
oh yeah we all need some more laughter
and a horror comedy is perfect
because i feel like the comedy and more
are just like
great together quite well together yeah
oh god it's so much fun to make
like honestly like i'm on set all the
time just like laughing at seth
and like the ridiculous thing so good in
this movie
guess when i play i play like a really
crazy oh i don't think i should be sure
i'm sorry but you play someone who's
quite into selfies
i love vlogging perfect i'm not a very
successful one
but like i tried even better yeah
exactly
who is yeah who's good at work
you know it's teach their own
and everything's like yeah but what you
your perception and what you put out
there anyways like yeah
i'm really really good i have so many
followers like it's all what you put out
there but
yeah so it's really crazy and we keep
like we just do not get along in the
film and so it's
kindred spirits yeah but we're two
really corrupt souls
but it's really funny i'm a little lower
on the
class scale and i'm too classy for him
so yeah you guys i mean you can see the
chemistry already between you two though
and
even for the movie that's going to read
really well in the show too
so i'm excited to see it but i i do want
to know
a little because i'm catching up here
like even with yousef
i so you're focusing on acting and
producing maybe going to do a book
uh maybe hopefully it's maybe i think i
think he's been convinced though
already yeah done
he's totally started doing it it's
already he's not
finished he's thinking about that right
now he's not even like listening to us
i will request that you make an
audiobook
version of it for me so i could just
like listen to it
instead and just like i love audiobooks
i love seth's voice actually
yeah it's like soothing awesome boys
that would yes
you should do an audio book yeah i read
out some things
one time when i wrote to them
oh you read
no if they're not scary the hook that's
that famous american horror story every
kid's read the hook
well about peter pan no no i mean there
is a hook in peter fan too with the
crocodile
you know he's doesn't have a left hand
he's got a hook instead
and then they hear the scratching sound
of the card they run away and when they
come back with their parents
the castle was scratched and there's a
hook on the car ooh
okay so we love that stories yeah he
likes it
and if you don't tell him a proper scary
one he's waiting
like and then he's like there you go
how am i supposed to follow him did you
read him your script
and just be like all right this is my
name and he said that's good
oh my god very good
there's some ghost stories that are kind
of um constructive
so there's a guy there's a knight an
arturian knight who's traveling around
and he's in love with this servant girl
and his father forbids him
to marry her and has her disappear
and this guy's lost and he's wandering
around and he's she
seeks shelter in this kind of hut one
night or in this castle or something and
lights a fire and goes to sleep and this
door flies open and this witch and this
horrendous
person is standing there and you know
she says i need a place to sleep so he
lets her in
and he kind of looks after the witch and
puts it because compassion is the key
and he puts her to sleep and this place
and she says go and get me some
wood for a fire and make my bed and he
does all this for her
and the next morning she's transformed
into that servant girl again and she's
beautiful
and he ends up she said i was cursed
that if anyone would show me true
kindness i would
you know go back to normal right so
these
there's actually always some form of
darkness and fairy tales as well there's
always that
really very dark evil you know and
obviously love would conquer
all and you know everything would be
fine but there was always like some kind
of darkness and like
kind of eerie as well when you look at
it again
and you don't usually realize it until
you get older and you look back and
you're like oh that is
twisted
but yeah i love it it's like when i used
to watch a lot of
grim stories hans christian andersen
they particularly the brothers grim
they get quite violent i mean a prince
falls out of a tower and then scratches
his eyes on
uh rose bushes blinded yeah
so that's your favorite genre to kind of
for acting you enjoy
horror films the most no no i don't know
what my favorite genre is
actually i just anything that's
interesting you shouldn't be repetitive
if you're lucky i mean you know
to kind of get to get to mix it up is
great i think you've done every single
genre
i don't know i don't know you've done
love you've done period films you've
done horror comedy you've done comedy
you've done
drama you've done um
have you done no wait sci-fi sci-fi's
are not no no no no
is it not very it's not a very big genre
here though no
it's not sci-fi yeah maybe if if
um but you said i think that they make
it bigger
we've been talking about sci-fi meets
mythology in india
so i think with this 3d and cg
absolutely becoming really good yeah
i think we're getting this i think we're
getting there it's an exciting time
yeah but yeah i mean like honestly like
horror comedy as well was not a genre in
the past and then
he did one of the first horror comedies
which i absolutely
loved always you have to watch this film
amanda it is hilarious i'm waiting for
part two
yeah i hope they'd make it oh i'm still
hoping for parts you can make it
you're a producer get in there he did
make it
okay no part two but
like it's a zombie it's a zombie film
and he plays a fake
uh russian mafia in goa he's from
delhi i loved it he was like this fake
yeah
it was so good i've been to goa once
before
yeah oh yeah do you enjoy it
oh yeah oh yeah we know what you're
saying yeah i've been
but no it's awesome beautiful
you were here last year you went to
rajasthan right
why didn't we face that way
yeah that would have been a great you
guys not facing the sun
yeah this is actually yeah he's like
[ __ ]
you guys look great though i'm telling
you i know we're
we're a little bit shadowy i think
you're comparing yourselves to
the fact that i have like lights and uh
you have nice lighting but also we have
a really nice view behind
we do and i was showing you my view from
from my room this morning it was
like yeah it was gorgeous well i hope
you
guys are having so much fun on set i
know we only
we have so much time with stuff today
but it was amazing hearing your stories
like i
wanna i wanna see more from you and i
guess the only way i'm going to
is through that book that you put out so
or your movies that i can watch
so or i could just like stalk you
through jacqueline
so one of them again or
do you shoot something on set oh yeah
to ask him i was like oh no like how do
i ask
yeah and it's crazy because like i mean
um so many people look up to and you're
not on social media so it's so great to
actually like hear
like you in interviews and we get so
little a few yeah but i you know that's
the thing i mean just because you're not
in social media doesn't mean you're
anti-social you know i'm quite happy to
have a chat and love doing interviews
and you know all that and i like people
it's just you do you do
[Laughter]
well i mean jacqueline why you guys are
on set why don't you just like see the
idea
of our movie i mean
yeah content nudge you start here
yeah yeah he's like yeah
don't worry do you think we look like
sisters you guys
definitely look uh similar yeah
like there's something you could be he's
like well
[Laughter]
but you know if you do i've noticed if
ladies do similar makeup like
there were decades in indian cinema
where the top makeup
stylist would kind of do everyone and
everyone starts looking slightly similar
glasgow looks similar if they do the
same eyes and the same kind of
the same makeup they've got similar eye
makeup
wow
he knows more about us than we know
about us
you're right but he's i never noticed
that though actually it's so true we do
yeah it's instagram it's instagram
makeup i'm trying to look at your
eyebrows
like is that so like drive past the
magazine store you 100
sure who that was you're like is that
so-and-so is that salsa oh it's
like it's like halloween we're just
dressing up
as each other every day
for comparing us to halloween it was
like dress
dress up
sorry amazing all righty thank you so
much
for your time enjoying this segment with
us
oh dude you want to hang out we're
keeping you you're you're right that's
right
we're having a lovely little barbecue
tonight we have to prepare your
party yeah we're having a little nice
diwali party tonight seth is throwing it
and uh it's gonna be i think a long
night
no it can't
i think it's the nicest time of year in
india everyone's in a good mood
and it's like nicely lit and the big
thing now is is to try and make it
a little eco-friendly and not burn too
many five actually not burn any
um sort of crackers crackers that mess
up the atmosphere i
love that yeah oh i love that
yeah and you know if you go to a small
village in india like i've driven
through
and you know they're very poor and it's
tiny and they're little
mud huts but even they will put a few
yeah
what are they called not just diaz but
these these kind of mud
oil lamps um in the window you know and
it just looks so
amazing yeah it's so charming i mean
because light is everything isn't it
yeah oh light is everything without
light we look at you
with that light this would not be good
this will not be good
that's so true but amanda
you've never been away from your family
i'm sure i have but normally
we get a few days off and we go down
yeah a couple of days
at least yeah try not to it's important
kind of time to be home
and you know light that little diy in
your own house supposedly a ritual good
luck
and say the prize okay so i guess this
year it's a little bit different than
every other year right they're coming to
us but i mean you know home is
a suitcase and where your heart is i
mean actually it's like your family's
with you
sorry i'm so scared
it's a party but they've done it they've
done it already they've gone to
and and they really also my wife's gone
to her manager's office
oh she's the one who gets her all the
jobs and that's where they've done the
main breath
because money so yeah that's actually
that was actually
it's very good it's almost pagan i love
it it's better than organized
you know um i love that too
absolutely
[Laughter]
yeah i agree i i think that's so fun i
love
i mean it's different than our fourth of
july
right like our independence day like
that's the only time that we're really
lighting things
up with like fireworks you know what i
think it's more it's more christmas
it's more christmas i would say yeah
like christmas lighting of the latter
day
yeah it's like christmas it's like
christmas because it's got lights
yeah that's true yeah presents and
hanging out it's like
it's like on christmas that's my
favorite holiday so
i guess diwali is also my favorite
holiday
yes and things are actually cooling down
even in hot cities
yeah but you know a little bit like
australia and south africa
both have hot christmases
[Music]
well it's a little bit cooler in florida
but it's still
like yeah it's humid
and it's like 70s so it's like nice warm
weather 70 degree fahrenheit what is
that celsius that's like
i'm written version 40 40 yes
maybe yeah that's hot i just said i was
like
whatever sounds hot yes
that's it yeah so but i was from um
i was born in pennsylvania but i grew up
in connecticut so that's like the
northeast
of the us and we had snow
like white christmases every year and
then i moved to florida
in uh eighth grade and then it
just like it didn't feel the same
without a white christmas but
i still celebrate like hardcore i love
it
hardcore christmas baby you should have
seen her halloween
oh yeah i'm sure it was hardcore i
love holidays i love celebrating
i love reasons to celebrate yeah there's
a whole concept where
it's kind of more than the the meaning
of the thing itself is the
family ritual is the the idea of getting
together getting people to their show
so it's crazy so sri lanka has the most
amount of holidays in the world
it's the country with the most amount of
holidays yeah so there's there's
one um holiday once a month when there's
a full moon
so that's like like everything just
shuts down it's called the boya day and
it's like
it's a good day for yeah you know the
crazy thing about that is
the full moon i don't know if like you
it really affects us
like it affects human beings effects
like our being the way we are
because of the water the rise in water
and the tides
you think so i've heard this that that's
why when there's full moon like even
like the seas everything that's affected
because we're like 70
water there is there's a menstrual cycle
luna
well no it's not it's not but sometimes
it does coincide and
you don't want it
yeah it's double whammy that's where
lunatic comes from right
the word
um but it does so there's a holiday
every single month when there's a full
moon over there so
i mean but it's more of a holy thing as
well
um there's a holiday i
obviously you've heard of mercury
retrograde right but i feel like it
happens so often
i mean this is a whole different
situation but
every ever since i was learning about it
and figured it out i'm like okay we're
out of it now
and now we're back in it like it's like
every it happens so often and i don't
know if you if you
if you follow the planets and like their
readings and stuff let's do it but not
really
but i mean you know it destroys your
like
your days i believe in it somehow
something always
drastic and dramatic happens yeah and
i'm like i need to stop paying attention
to this because
i feel like sometimes me paying
attention to these things
i'm like putting the energy out there
yeah
and i'm bringing it into my own life and
i'm like okay like let me not pay
attention to
the schedule unless it's really awesome
all right guys i think like we've got
our um
i think we've got this segment i think
we do too
so so yes
done go for it what is this outro oh
oh we have to announce our winner yeah
we have a cash prize winner
every episode seth so i don't know if
you see that in front of you
but this is the comment that we got the
winning comment on
our review they give us five star
reviews and
if you want to read it dude you want to
read it
good vibe podcast others that don't read
it
[Laughter]
all right so let's see what um i hate
you
those are not great for me yes like
i hear you feel like
okay so her title was felt good and this
is what she said
mirage i said started my morning with
we're getting married so good it's like
having virtual girlfriends
got to learn about new places and new
terms oh you guys
have such a nice vibe is that us well
this is our last week
it's like it's about me it's not live
and you're like what's going on it's
like having virtual girlfriends
he's like thank you wait a minute wait a
minute
what did i say we're getting married
what have i got
myself that's quite funny but this was
last week's episode because we just we
we spoke about marriage
and um yeah so that's what we remember
the first episode
you're our first guest yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
after this podcast he's going to get off
and be like
oh that's what happened that's what
happened
that's what it is that's what it is
why did i do that we've already done
foreign
that's what it is just confuse them
it's good you have a great lineup behind
you
you got a lot of comedians behind you
you got a lot of actors behind you
oh for me if you could live in any
sitcom which one would it be
two and a half men oh really yeah don't
ask me who i want to be though
oh of course yeah yeah whatever
okay what is the scariest thing you've
ever done for fun
i'm sure frightening someone or dress
you know getting someone to dress up as
a
scariest thing you've ever done like
have you gone like bungee jumping and
stuff
no no like scared someone else or like
that
that's the scariest thing i guess
something to do with maybe
motorcycle cycles or something they were
a bit scary
driving nascar fast what is that i did
as they stop driving whatever it's
called yeah yeah but they're very hot
and they all open up so that when you
drive fast you're getting hit in the
head with
fumes and hot so i was very
claustrophobic
and this guy teaching me was luckily
there was a driver on the track and he
looked across at me
and he said you're right and i said oh
you can't breathe and he said
yeah you gotta want you gotta want it
it's true though
i was just thinking like everything
racing in that condition
imagine being the actual driver though
i did that in a formula one card two two
i was in the um
the back and then it was just like your
whole body is
the whole time just like
with such heavy weights in the video
with this just to get his
you know negative like even like the
next
oh my god that's crazy okay there's
another one here if you could eliminate
one thing from your daily routine
what would it be and why it's probably
some kind of a
diet or say eating something stupid i'm
sure at some point but you don't really
eat
no i don't but i do sometimes i can keep
especially in hotel rooms
no it's like mini bar like not the
alcohol but i walk in there just
eat you crispy it is super tempting
pringles or something
in just be like hey can you empty them
check this out
i've done that really often and there's
always something
they're like oh yeah yeah let's just
mess with him
or they give you like the welcome gift
in your hotel room it's
all chocolates and yes thanks yeah
exactly
we've got that here yeah we did we got
like our little like
chocolate phone that says the chocolates
it was like from
our instagram it was like an instagram
page like our post
okay is that from yeah it's from my
instagram are you serious
hey there's perks and instagram stuff
you gotta get
in on some little beans to be made as
well yeah i miss my
lockdowns my wife's on
from social media without even being on
social media how clever is that
yeah that is great yeah
he's faking his crap
yeah it's like this is the smartest like
way to go ahead with it i mean i think
this is the future
just like make money from it without
being on it i love it since you're so
good at making money
um if you had to wear a t-shirt with one
one word on it for one year
which would you choose and you could
sell these
piece piece pizza is good
i like
me and amanda have got a word guess what
our word is
juice juice white juice what did you say
i said jam
jam
[Laughter]
half listening if you're
handling yeah
jackie and amanda make jam because jay
oh
so um i reached out to amanda
on instagram oh you guys met on the
graham
yes i dm'ed her and i was coming to l.a
and i was like i have to meet her
because she just
she does the funniest funniest skits and
like i've followed her you know on
instagram for ages
and um like truly a fan
but but um so yeah like i just come to
ellie i was like maybe i should message
her should i try
i tried and she responded and she's like
yeah cool let's let's meet up
oh nice it makes the world smaller and
it's lovely isn't it and we
we caught up for coffee you know like
that you know what
when we got in and then it was just from
there
we've just been then i became a fan and
i'm like
you will never leave my site
[Laughter]
nobody knows who actually is you've
brought him in here three times
he could he can pay for it and you can
interview both police people
oh for the jam for the job yeah like
just a show
why did you show up to publicize movies
oh there you go like you want to
publicize your and i'd have
movies i was like what are people to do
that though or is that you guys must
watch this movie featuring jacqueline
fernandez
let me help you i can be like the jam
interviewer if you want
no this is great i want to play
smallhead why
that says done oh yeah well you will do
caps and t-shirts
i i think he's starting to produce
our podcasts oh his natural instincts
are coming in
we got him just where we wanted him yes
mission accomplished and then it will be
a movie
look at that that's my step before stuff
[Laughter]
we have you on camera that's cool man
i'll do it
yay success i mean
you heard it here first folks it's
happening
good news we're gonna title our episode
next week
we got a movie new bollywood film new
bollywood meets hollywood film content
crossover produced by crosstalk together
celebrity guest
it's it's when they collide so it's
happening
we just need some cash now
finances a jam production let's get them
on our show next
week amanda let's get actually
yeah foreign and then by the end of it
we'll have a movie i think you should do
it get him on that's
i'll come and do what he's doing the
truth is there's a podcast
i want to watch yes
this podcast is just a promotion for
our future movie yeah i mean that's all
this is
yeah i see that i know that that's where
it's going
just to make things clear yeah not yeah
i'm always up front
um all right another question from our
fans
since oh you gave us more time so we're
really don't make your time here all
right cool let's just do like let's do
one more
and then oh this is the last one i made
oh would you rather be able to talk with
animals or speak all foreign these are
from
your fans by the way would you rather be
able to talk with animals or speak
all foreign languages well that's a
really good question that is a tough one
i don't know how to answer that
and can i speak like 10 languages and to
10 animals
split it up no i think i would rather uh
my gosh i think i'd rather speak to
animals yeah because
you know language is all the same
they're just you know different versions
of the song and that is definitely
something you can learn
but this is a slightly different
superpower unless it's a really boring
conversation with like a chicken where
you say
what's up and he says i don't know i'm
reaching this thing
what else is nothing else we've all seen
like damn i should have taken languages
like they just don't
spoken to your body
and what if different i wonder if
different animals around the world
this is a deep late night thought for me
guys whoa
i wonder if animals around the world
speak different
languages like in like a dog
in different countries yeah yeah like a
dog in l.a
of course they would what is a different
language it's the same thought
expressed with different sounds right
from from the community that you're the
ideas
ideas are not different like a chinese
person won't say you know
the t is on the table i mean that's the
same idea
it's just different sounds and like from
different communities yeah there would
be
rivers sound the same everywhere what
sounds like
rivers and trees sound i mean like wind
yeah
so they say accents are based on like i
read some
environment yes like someone lived near
the river and
it had some smelly fish in it or people
caught fish and they became they were
nasals
and they were more nasal because they
were smelling a lot of you know
he's totally adding to our fun facts
like this is actually fun
right can you tell me where my accent
like what was my environment
from my accent but you told us that i
didn't say that you sound like someone
who started off in a northeast of
america
and it probably went down south to
warmer climates
[Music]
no this is about those irish or those
kind of you know very strong accents are
sometimes governed by
environment yeah i mean like because
everyone sounds so distinct right and
yeah like people
in the desert sound different from
people living in an island and people
so it's bombing oh my god it's really
hard
i keep getting in trouble froze
um like voices and accents
like yeah they will facing their i want
to go
so bad i've never been to ireland i
really want to go i was going to go for
my birthday this year but then it's
abandoned
trinity college dublin which is quite
nice a really nice place island's
beautiful island
and the walks and nature is amazing also
what's that one movie i watched it and
just made me want to go
it's always
did you see ps i love you though it's
very different
yeah i know we're like yes i love you
the devil's hat
have you seen me i'm not watching psl no
i'm not going to watch it either
oh my god it's so good it's like
come on oh i bet you'll cry
i bet you you'll cry i know i cried
i don't want to cry i get very
that scared our other question yeah but
what was it
afraid of what scares you
cockroaches cockroaches oh
uh in incontinence
incontinence i have terrible uh story
about that in context
it's like when you when you can't
control going to the loo oh i didn't
know it's called that
it's one of the beauties of incontinence
you know getting older you could look
forward
i did take a bathroom break in our other
podcasts
it's time for stuff yeah fun facts
well you you'll never want to come to
florida because we have
flying i like people in florida quite
often i can't handle that
it's too you know once i was watching tv
at home and i had the window open
in lokinwala in bombay and i was
watching tv
and i felt something land on my knee and
i really thought it was a very light
little fly because it was so soft oh my
god and i just while watching tv i just
like looked at my knee and this
big cockroach that big and i went oh
yeah i start to cry
i start to cry i would also start
correct oh
yeah i spent no i start to cry when you
don't see where they went
like if you saw it and then it's gone
because then we have ones that fly where
is it
i can't sleep yeah yeah i have to rip up
all the furniture
same thing spiders spiders do you have
like uh
nets on your windows to stop that
happening mosquito net
yeah that kind of or yeah like the i'm
johnny yeah
no you just let them get
you're welcome i think alex are quite
good-looking are they like not
good-looking cockroaches
they're very ugly are they big super big
this is the house
shooting and there was a locust kind of
attack and the first lot of lookers
were quite scary biblical scary yeah but
a week later
these very good-looking green ones
arrived that were not as disturbing at
all was this
the uh resisting quarantine no it's not
because there was
the great migration what of what
the butterflies of butterflies yeah
it's all monarch butterflies just like
flying down the roads
like thousands of them beautiful
yeah i was like what is this that would
be beautiful butterflies like their
colors and their brains
butterflies probably quite big oh oh
well they're they're the orange ones
right
but how big are they come on butterflies
no matter how big they are they're not
scary
moths moths are scary yeah
yeah mods poor guys can't do it like
butterflies are so beautiful and then
there's like there's mods
yeah that's a story about the lotuses
really made me think about the
cockroaches
and how i said they're all ugly you know
maybe i just need to give them a chance
i know no they're quite scary okay okay
yeah exactly this is positive this feels
good
salman rushdie wrote this lovely short
story or book
i mean in the satanic verses about this
lady who's
discovered in butterflies and she's you
know this is where the king sees her and
he falls in love with her and there's
this
but very descriptive beautiful writer
but he writes this lovely piece about
butterflies
oh good higher thing for a movie yeah is
he gets hired to write movie scripts
[Laughter]
is it is it from the compilation of
different writers or is this
no this is his book the satanic verses
yeah that's when the ayatollah popular
chapter in america
um yeah and his life changed he was
he had to change his name to joseph
antonin
no no um
there was a islamic death sentence
passed by the
ayatollah khomeini the to the spiritual
leader of iran
you know that movie argo oh yeah yeah
yeah
he's the guy who kind of you know hates
america the great satan
oh so they so basically is where like
you get banned because you've gone
against death it's just oh it's a death
okay yeah because you've
gone again well he did right exactly
that the best brothel in the world was
in mecca and
you know the women are named after
sort of wives of the prophet or
something wow so it didn't go down too
well
no yeah but he changed his name he had
to change his name to joseph anton
which uh named after two of his favorite
writers uh
joseph conrad and anton chekhov
who's a russian playwright wow um and
his book he's written an autobiography
called
joseph anthony and and do people know
his whereabouts does he get
he's cool now he's in in india i mean
and he's in england it's fine now it was
lifted and all was forgiven
and everything was okay but for many
years everyone has had sort of special
security in london and his life changed
wow that is scary there's so many
[Music]
yeah so you guys go have so much fun for
diwali and make sure that
did i say it right now it's diwali
foreign
[Laughter]
oh i will i love oh wait hold on
[Music]
happy you got one oh oh my god nice
bali spread the light
oh that looks like a nice candle is that
a charcoal candle
i don't know they sent it to me it's
it's pretty
what's the chocolate oh it smells so
good that's beautiful well done
celebration happy diving
lovely awesome i can't wait to see
the post from you jacqueline seth i'll
live
i'll wait for your videos all right i've
got it ready
i don't know i do i just want i'll send
it to you now just have a look at it
oh cool awesome perfect done and done
i love it all right guys thank you so
much